Xander what's up buddy what do you got
for me tonight
um nothing much can you hear me all
right yeah you're loud and clear awesome
good so I have a situation you were
talking about like men betraying men
earlier
um so I have an X
that says the mother of my child uh my
daughter lived with her and
he cheated on me with a friend of mine
who now beats her
so and I'm in Texas and Texas has Penal
Code 22.06 uh mutual combat
should I initiate a fight with this guy
underneath that penal code to get him to
leave for the protection of both her and
my daughter
okay so let me see if I understand this
correctly so your ex you have a daughter
with her she's living with a guy that's
physically abusive to her and your child
not much nailed just her but I'm worried
about it uh translating over to her
called your daughter
she just turned two in December yeah
what are the one of the biggest risks
for children especially little girls is
non-blood red non-blood relatives living
in that same house girls that like moms
that make bad choices and bring losers
like this into the house expose your kid
to significant risk anything from
physical abuse to sexual abuse you you
like you need to have a conversation
with your kid's mom about [__] like this
she's not going to want to hear it she's
she's gonna oh don't worry about it I
got it under control look man
if you date enough women and they start
telling you about their childhood and
their uh you know their Growing Pains
you hear a lot of stories about Step
Brothers and stepfathers abusing whether
physically or sexually when they were
growing up setting that aside
sorry so what's this so what's this
Texas Penal Code so what is this like a
duel like you challenge them to a duel
exactly it's a fist against fist uh with
no intention of serious bodily harm it's
basically like hey if you all want to
have a fist fight you can as long as you
both agree to this Penal Code no legal
repercussions nobody can go to jail so I
would print it off have us both sign it
and you know
that's interesting so it's like a boxing
match
yeah essentially except for your
probably bare knuckle fighting him
yes
um
I don't know that I like that
I don't I don't know if I like it either
but this particular guy I've known him
since I was in high school and that's
pretty much the only thing that he
responds to is he a match is he a mooch
like is he living off her or is she
living off him
uh uh he actually lives on his own
somewhere but before that he he actually
was cheating on his girlfriend
uh when he didn't have a job
with uh
my uh my ex when your extras change the
locks in the house and just get rid of
them
she doesn't want to get rid of him
that's the thing oh okay so she's an
idiot then basically
has a little bit of an understatement I
mean you have do you have shared custody
of your kid
there is no uh custody in place we just
have a verbal agreement I get her every
single weekend and just about every
weekend I go over there his truck is
there his bike is there
I mean this is a problem for your kid
more than anything I wouldn't worry
about the kid's mom because she's going
to do what she's going to do and she
clearly doesn't make very intelligent
choices so that's not going to change
um
what I would be aiming at doing is
getting getting more time with the kid
and maybe even having custody of the kid
because if she's not with this douchebag
that's beating her or like doing
whatever it is that he happens to be
doing she's just going to replace him
with another douchebag
yeah like women that make these bad
choices with with men that they select
that they want to invite in their lives
they tend to do it over and over again
right and at some point your kid's going
to get caught up in the crossfire now do
you want to challenge him to a duel and
fight him
go for it if you want but
like what are the outcomes
he beats the living [__] out of you you
walk away with your tail between your
legs you beat the living [__] out of him
he walks away with his tail between the
legs you beat the crap out of each it
doesn't matter people are gonna get beat
yeah right how old are you
turned 31 in March do you know how to
fight
a little bit yeah does he know how to
that one I don't know
um
he's he's kind of this guy that tells a
lot of stories and I don't really know
the validity of all of them
um
so I really don't know
but with the the way that he boasts
about it kind of insinuates that he
doesn't really know how to see it I mean
the problem with this is It's kind of
Simply Behavior because you're trying to
protect the honor of Milady
right like the main reason why you're
and why because she's behaving like an
idiot like why does she even have this
guy in her life would be the first
question I'd be like why would you fight
a guy that's banging your ex lives in
the house with her and she doesn't want
to get rid of him like what's the point
of that like what is the best possible
outcome here
the best possible outcome is you win and
you send him off with his tail between
his legs and probably nothing will
change the worst is that he beats the
living crap out of you and embarrasses
you and he's now the dominant Alpha
gorilla here
hmm
my thought process it wasn't even
necessarily about my ex it was just a
fact of uh violence seems like the only
thing that he responds to
and well violence is a solution but it
should be a last last Stitch type of
solution what other avenues can you go
down to get rid of this loser and get
him away from your daughter because it's
not about your ex girlfriends about
getting away from your daughter
yeah uh so
I actually do have a business idea
um
that
if I can get it going it'll gross 800k a
year net 600. if I can get that going
then I will have the financial ability
to hire whoever I want and just
be able to just take my daughter's no
question to ask because she's in no
position she lives I'm pretty certain is
what's considered Section 8 housing now
governmental housing
um
the fact of this dude is abusive and
there's actually a CPS case open right
now because somebody what did you guys
part ways why aren't why are you
together with your kids mom
why am I not yeah why are you not with
her oh uh because I was an over the road
truck driver and this guy was one of my
friends and she was cheating on me with
him while I was on the road and the it
came to a head three days before my
birthday of last year uh when I got a
call at two o'clock in the morning this
guy threatened our landlord and he
evicted us and that was where we split
up well do you remember the sort of show
we were talking about friends and this
guy was a friend of yours this guy is
not only the kind of guy that beats
women but he's also the kind of guy that
bangs your girlfriend while you're
driving on the road very very
weak-minded yeah so a lot of all of this
like the root of a lot of all these
problems starts with you my friend
like if you have if you have to get to
the point where your only option is to
challenge the guy to a duel and violence
is the only way that you think that you
can solve this
like you've arrived here today like the
results that you have right now in your
life with this crazy ex with this
ex-friend of yours that's now banging
your racks and around your daughter a
lot a woman that you have a child with
that you don't see as much as you'd like
to and your best response to all of this
is let's challenge him to a duel you
have to have better options right I mean
like the like the beliefs that you're
using to make these choices to get these
results aren't really working for you
the thing that you can control is
yourself here you can't control your ex
and who she chooses you can't control
your ex you know she banged this guy
your friend's a piece of [__] you know
he's banging your girlfriend while
you're on the road like
you just take all of these ingredients
you can put them in a blender and you
turn it on turn on the blender and
you've got a [__] Shake
right and I mean a lot of this all
starts with you and and leveling
yourself up and putting yourself in a
better position so that you're not
dealing with [__] women so that you're
not dealing with [__] friends that'll
Bang You're a girl right so you're not
dealing with women that'll bang your
best friend
right women that can look up to you and
see who is their best option so they're
not going to run around like this
everything else is just temporary like
everything else that you're that you're
talking about is just a Band-Aid
some of the fighting yeah it's all just
abandoned man like the like the
self-improvement like working on
yourself is where you need to go it's a
longer term plan and it's a longer term
plan it's a much longer term plan but
it's what needs to happen here so you
don't end back up in the same scenario
because in 12 months you could be having
a safe conversation got a new girl we
knocked her up she cheated on me when I
was on the road she's banging another
friend of mine you're gonna end up in
the same boat again right
I'd be asking questions like why did I
choose a chick that would bang my friend
why did I have a friend in my inner
circle that would bang my girl
why is this guy abusive to women like
why am I hanging around guys that beat
women right
see what I'm saying
yeah duel duel is your only option
challenge him to a duel is your only
option you know at this stage but you've
got to make better choices going forward
yeah it was actually this
particular incident uh that actually
full on red pilled me and I read your
book uh oh God
the unplugged Alpha and going through
the red flags chapter
yeah she she ticked a lot of boxes on
that do you have any do you have any
social services that you can call on as
a father Child Protective Services I've
got concerns you know this guy because
he's beating the mother you know could
potentially be you know beat my child do
you have any recourse there with public
services
well well uh I know I kind of said it as
a little statement earlier but there is
actually a CPS file Protective Service
case open right now uh because somebody
reported I'm not sure who
that he was beating on her and so they
were worried about the kids as well
um
I would definitely build on that too
make it difficult for him make it
difficult for her
well the thing I'm worried about with
making it difficult for her is her
knowing that I'm trying to make it
difficult for her and then her just
going down to the what is it uh not
district attorney
the place where these women go for uh
child support and all that kind of stuff
and make it to where that I'm just not
able to see my daughter at all and just
because you know
in America
women have more support in that than
yeah I mean like you work though like
you've got an income
yeah yeah okay well I mean like you have
a custody schedule like you see in the
kid
uh
like I said we had the verbal agreement
where I get her every weekend
well look I mean like verbal agreements
aren't
aren't the best you want something a
little bit more enforceable you want a
little bit more of a precedent right
like you want something that's more like
in writing obviously yeah take take your
daughter whenever you can offer you know
I've got some spare time this weekend
why don't you go and do whatever you got
to do things you got to catch up on I'll
take her to Chuck E cheese and you know
we'll do some stuff together daddy
daughter sort of night
like you know take those opportunities
that's the better use of your time you
know my opinion than challenging a man
to a duel but if that's all you got then
that's what you got right
um
that was uh
the most quickest
thing that I could think of because of
uh you know how unlevel or unequal the
legal system is as far as like family
logos
yeah
well if you're going to do it make sure
you win man make sure you enter that
realm of of combat with a
a strong position and you know the
ability to win it um make sure you know
what you're doing because
uh fighting is it's not something to be
taken lightly man
yeah I know that's that's one of the
reasons why I came on here and asked
start look like honestly man take a good
look at yourself and and ask yourself
beliefs choices results beliefs lead to
choices that you make every day choices
will lead to the results that you got
you you have an internal belief
somewhere that led you to believe that
she would be a good choice to sleep with
to put a baby in to start a relationship
with you made a choice at some point
based on your beliefs that you hold true
to allow this guy to be your friend to
introduce him to your girl maybe hang
out together at some point invite him
over for a barbecue you know like you've
you've held these beliefs
within yourself
to drive to choices that have gotten you
the results that you're at today
this is the part of the universe that
you can control the best is your belief
system fixing your belief system and
making better choices will avoid these
kinds of results in the future
just step back and look at it from that
perspective
all right
yeah all right Xander good luck with
that I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out